yeah president biden facing fire from
all sides over the border crisis the
squalid camp under a bridge in del rio
texas once holding nearly 15 000
migrants mostly haitians now nearly
empty joining us with more on this texas
congressman dan crenshaw congressman
great to have you i know you listened to
the president just moments ago i was
kind of stunned at the very top he was
talking about the border agents the
mounted border agents on patrols and and
he was saying things that are absolutely
not true we have looked at this video
analysts have looked at this video it
did not happen there were no whips used
on these people and yet you have people
in the administration including the
president continuing to propagate this
and in fact can we play that we have
that sound and congress can we just play
that sound and then have you react to it
please
sure to see people treat it like they
did horses really running over people
being strapped it's outrageous i promise
you those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
he also said that it was an
embarrassment uh and that it's a
dangerous and wrong congressman
yeah you know that was probably the the
part of his speech in the last 30
minutes that made me the angriest like
we could take an hour debunking all the
lies that he told on all different
subjects and there was a lot
but this one was really egregious look
it seems like the only people he wants
to hold accountable for the mess at the
border is his own border agents for
doing their job he put them in this
position and then he lies about what
they're doing he lies about their
actions you can't imagine a worse leader
right now
if you're trying to get a mass exodus
from the border patrol if you're trying
to get them to quit and lose morale then
this is a great way to do it
i mean
to blame them and you know who else
isn't held accountable all the people
illegally crossing our border all the
unvaccinated all the people with covet
all the people infiltrating our country
and lying about their asylum claims
they're not held accountable
but biden doesn't care about that look
and we have to stop pretending like this
is incompetence this isn't incompetence
they're doing this on purpose uh
majorcas was on the record what
yesterday bragging about how there's too
many of trump's policies that they've
rescinded to even count so they
rescinded all these policies they act
surprised that it causes this mass
migration across our border this
unsustainable mass migration
and
they act like it's you know just a tough
situation that they have to deal with
but it's not it was done on purpose
yeah
yeah and i guess that's the question is
you know you look at this congressman
and you talk about what the president is
saying and then you look down at the
border and we've been trying now for a
couple of days to get secretary marcus
the administration to give us numbers
right we know there are about 3 500 of
those haitian immigrants still down
under that bridge in del rio texas we
know about 1800 1400 have been taken
back to haiti we don't know how many
were released into the united states but
it's in the thousands and we cannot get
exact numbers and yet we know they do
have the numbers
well it gets worse than that look
everybody's focused on the haitians
right now
these are mostly single men it's much
easier to deport them under whether it's
under title 42 or under other
immigration laws everybody's focused on
that right now
don't lose sight of the fact that well
over a million encounters have occurred
this year and they won't give us numbers
on how many of them have been released
so that's going to be in the hundreds of
thousands right and over a million what
does that mean that means the eighth
largest city in america that means a
population the size of the eighth
largest city in america
has infiltrated our country and this
administration doesn't care it's it's
it's a dereliction of constitutional
duty because he's willingly he's
willingly refusing and deliberately
refusing to enforce laws congressman
thank you for watching the speech with
us and for being the first to react to
it we appreciate you and we'll be in
touch with you soon thank you
congressman thank you sir thanks dana hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now